[Applauso]
oggi vorrei incominciare con una domanda
una domanda che mi frulla per i capelli
da un po' di
tempo è più interessante la realtà o la
fantasia quando ero una una bimba una
bambina mi rifugiavo per delle ore nelle
mie avventure fantastiche a spasso per
gli angoli più reconditi della casa non
da sola ero ben accompagnata da dei
peluche ovviamente totalmente dotati di
carattere autonomo E personalità molto
ben definita in quel momento la fantasia
era
soltanto diciamo era il posto dove mi
divertivo di più dove tutto poteva
succedere la fantasia era più spassosa
il mondo della fantasia era più
avventuroso ho vissuto un'infanzia
ovattata molto protetta ma non me ne
rendevo conto proprio perché appunto
sotto la sede della cucina o dietro il
mobile del salotto poteva succedere
qualunque cosa una piccola bruciatura
della moquette poteva diventare il
cratere di un vulcano ogni piccolo
particolare si riempiva di
significato Diciamo che la realtà il
mondo reale era soltanto lo spazio
fisico il palcoscenico dove prendeva
vita il contenuto della Fantasia Poi
però sono cresciuta e crescendo ho
alzato lo sguardo e quando uno cresce
acquista anche più autonomia più libertà
di movimento e quindi mi sono guardata
in giro e ho notato che il mondo reale
era pieno zeppo di contenuti fantastici
è stata una scoperta incredibile
bellissima era come aver inghiottito uno
de quei filtri per la realtà aumentata
non so se avete presente come quando
inquadrate un edificio e vi esce fuori
una piovra gigante Ecco lì che è
iniziato un bellissimo dialogo tra
questi due mondi tra il mondo della
realtà e il mondo della fantasia il
mondo della fantasia mi permetteva di
plasmare di trasformare in qualche modo
la realtà e il mondo reale forniva
continui spunti per andare ad alimentare
nuove
idee spunti come questo per esempio
questa è la fotografia di una saponetta
che era stata morsicata da mio figlio
quando aveva un anno e mezzo poco tempo
dopo in studio Abbiamo ricreato abbiamo
creato questa fotografia una fotografia
che non soltanto è finita nel nostro
Magazine ma Ma poi è finita anche su dei
piatti su dei bicchieri è diventata
Addirittura una seduta di Radical design
italiano per poi ritrasformare in una
saponetta morsicata ma sempre
utile un altro esempio di contaminazione
visiva tra questi due mondi sempre in
questo caso parliamo di contaminazione
visiva è il mondo dei mercati da sempre
scat fotografie in giro per i mercati
questi sono mercati reali che poi hanno
dato spunto per un mercato di fantasia
ricreato da zero in studio per dei
grandi magazzini francesi a Parigi Ecco
il modo in cui ognuno di noi guarda la
realtà è unico è ugualmente
valido Questo spiega perché per esempio
uno dei miei figli vede dei mostri
abominevoli nelle ombre del bagno e
l'altro non ci vede assolutamente nulla
o perché se io dico la parola cane
ognuno di voi sicuramente si starà
immaginando un cane diverso chi un
chihuahua chi un pastore tedesco e così
via Ecco io penso che se non
valorizziamo questa nostra lente
personale questo modo unico in cui
guardiamo la realtà e che poi ci
permette di immaginare cose diverse di
pensare ognuno di noi una cosa diversa
Non stiamo valorizzando il nostro
potenziale più grande Ovvero la nostra
unicità perché l'unicità è anche data da
come guardiamo e riceviamo ciò che ci
arriva dal mondo che ci
circonda ognuno ci smuove qualcosa
dentro no E quel qualcosa che ci muove e
poi ci fa creare qualcosa di nuovo delle
idee un prodotto un concetto ognuno poi
processa in modo differente No ognuno ha
il suo modus operandi il mio avviene più
o meno così il tutto parte
dall'osservare che non è proprio
guardare è come un
guardare
analizzando
dopodiché le informazioni vengono
memorizzate vengono memorizzate in delle
cartelle questa parte a volte è
inconscia e a volte conscia non sempre
decidiamo che cosa vogliamo memorizzare
ma di solito quando qualcosa ci colpisce
lo
memorizziamo dopodiché le informazioni
vengono digerite
assimilate tutto ha bisogno di un tempo
per essere decantato e come avviene
proprio nel processo digestivo a volte
gli elementi che raccogliamo subiscono
delle piccole trasformazioni in questo
in questo processo dopo avviene la fase
che a me piace di più lo shaker Aggio in
questa fase dobbiamo permettere Almeno
io cerco di permettere che tutte le
informazioni raccolte memorizzate Si
mescolino tra loro per consentire dei
link delle connessioni anche inusuali e
inaspettate per poi al momento opportuno
servire un piatto
originale Io credo che il segreto di un
buon risultato è che tutti gli
ingredienti devono essere in equilibrio
tra loro come non so come in un buon
cocktail o come in una bella sinfonia Ma
anche in una squadra di calcio non si
può fare una squadra solo di fantasisti
no poi naturalmente dipende da Qual è il
vostro scopo Qual è lo scopo di ognuno m
per chi stiamo creando qualcosa nel mio
caso creare immagini originali significa
non per forza trovare un risultato che
sia armonico anzi spesso e volentieri
cerchiamo La provocazione l'ironia il
grottesco per creare qualcosa che sia un
po' memorabile immagini come
questa o ancora come
questa Vediamo come il prendere qualcosa
di reale e mescolarlo con un prodotto
della
Fantasia crea una sorta di Corto
Circuito e questo corto circuito in
qualche modo rende l'immagine più
potente più
memorabile anche in questo caso per
esempio siamo partiti da oggetti
semplici quotidiani normale un panino un
rospo ma il fatto di averli messi
insieme ha creato questo corto
circuito certo Voi direte facile fai
creatività fai pubblicità campagne di
moda arte ma non è proprio così nel
senso che ci siamo resi conto che queste
immagini possono essere utili anche per
raccontare fatti reali fatti di cronaca
come nel caso di questi articoli di
attualità per il New York Times
vediamo di nuovo come immaginazione e
realtà si mescolano collaborano tra loro
e si potenziano a vicenda in questa
immagine per esempio abbiamo
accompagnato un articolo che parlava
della lotta tra i Titani del Tech che
invece di cercare di collaborare tra di
loro si fanno
guerra
ecco ma oggi non sono qui soltanto per
parlare delle immagini o del processo
creativo che c'è dietro sono qui perché
mi sono resa conto di come l'aver
allenato quel
muscolo quel continuo dialogo tra il
mondo della realtà e il mondo della
fantasia mi abbia aiutato non soltanto
nel mio lavoro ad esprimermi meglio ma
nella mia vita privata Nella mia vita di
tutti i giorni credo che abbia aiutato
ad essere la mia vita Un po' più
interessante un po' più fluida ma
soprattutto più ricca di
opportunità Nonostante oggi parliamo
molto di fluidità siamo ancora molto
ancorati ad un mondo binario di bianco
di nero di scienza di religione di
realtà di fantasia ma dobbiamo per forza
scegliere Robert John auman è un
matematico razionalista convinto Premio
Nobel per l'economia nel 2005 ma è anche
un uomo di Fede quando in un'intervista
gli è stato chiesto se non vivesse un
perenne conflitto tra scienza e
religione e con Che strumento
rispondesse alle domande più importanti
egli rispose in questo modo quando mangi
una bistecca che posate usi la forchetta
e il coltello quando mangi il gelato il
cucchiaio Ecco così come ogni alimento
richiede una posata diversa ogni realtà
richiede uno strumento di ricerca adatto
scienza e religione mi permettono di
guardare il mondo e la vita da
prospettive
diverse stessa cosa per realtà è
fantasia sono entrambi mondi utili da
cui attingere al momento opportuno ma
non in modo binario un giorno sono tutta
creativa e un giorno Sono iper razionale
piuttosto in modo più simbiotico più
fluido che ci permetterà di essere più
dinamici di rotolare e di andare più
avanti nella
vita di religione ebraica e sono
cresciuta con l'idea che dovevo sposarmi
con un ebreo o avrei completamente perso
il mio ebraismo quale ero e sono molto
legata questa era la realtà ma per
fortuna poi c'era la fantasia ho
fantasticato ho immaginato che mi sarei
potuta innamorare di chi volevo e che un
giorno avrei incontrato una persona fine
a me per spiritualità e che avrebbe
lasciato che io vivessi l'ebraismo a
modo mio fortunatamente ho incontrato
quella persona anni dopo in Argentina
proveniente da una famiglia irlandese
Cattolica quindi non c'entrava niente e
con lui abbiamo avuto tre figli e ogni
venerdì sera cantiamo e celebriamo lo
Shabbat dunque quando sono stata messa
Davanti a questa scelta ho avuto paura
sì Ero terrorizzata terrorizzata di fare
una scelta irrimediabilmente
sbagliata Il cuore mi diceva una cosa la
testa me ne diceva un'altra cosa fare ma
ecco l'aver immaginato l'aver
fantasticato un finale diverso da quello
prestabilito mi ha permesso di uscire da
questo Vicolo Cieco in cui
ero in cui ero il pensiero creativo la
creatività oggi è una competenza ed è
applicabile a tutto a
tutti Alcune persone dicono di non
essere Creative di non avere fantasia ma
è impossibile ed è un peccato sentir
dire questo perché io penso che sia uno
strumento che tutti abbiamo dentro ed è
davvero molto utile sicuramente uno dei
blocchi per l'intuizione creativa è
proprio la paura ma se ci pensiamo bene
Che cos'è la paura appare una forma di
fantasia sto fantasticando un finale
tragico sto immaginando un futuro che
ancora non esiste e Dun lo vediamo Siamo
tutti
creativi Oggi viviamo come abbiamo visto
dalle precedenti doc in un mondo pieno
di problemi problemi anche estremamente
complessi E che cosa facciamo quando
abbiamo un problema e non riusciamo a
risolverlo abbiamo paura e che cosa
facciamo quando abbiamo
paura ci rifugiamo in delle risposte
razionali uno dei primi istinti è quello
no qualcosa che ci dà sicurezza che
conosciamo già Ebbene Io penso invece
che proprio nel momento storico in cui
stiamo vivendo dove siamo continuamente
bombardati da notizie che ci mettono
paura che ci mettono l'ansia che ci
fanno sentire stabili la capacità di
cambiare di essere flessibili e di
immaginare nuove possibilità può essere
la nostra
salvezza se ci rinchiudiamo nella
razionalità stiamo semplicemente
riducendo le
opportunità le salsiccie non sono
cosciere Scusate eh Mentre se ci apriamo
alla creatività ci apriamo a un mondo
intero di nuove possibilità e quindi e
quindi creiamoci uno spazio uno spazio
dove pensare liberamente senza esprimere
giudizio dove allenare quel muscolo che
ci permette di aprire i nostri orizzonti
e non di chiuderli e io sono sicura che
ciò ci porterà a un'esistenza più ricca
di significato più libera e meno
scontata e quindi quando abbiamo
un'intuizione cosa dobbiamo fare quando
abbiamo
un'idea la prima cosa da fare è cercare
di entusiasmarsi di corrergli dietro di
mettersi all lavoro poi Si scoprirà se è
un'idea che non porta da nessuna parte
ma se Iniziamo a pensare che conseguenze
avrà no che cosa ci guadagnerò o che
cosa ci perderò ci stiamo probabilmente
preoccupando per il problema
sbagliato Non sto dicendo che sia facile
Non è facile passeremo per forza dei
momenti di fragilità e di solitudine
proprio perché stiamo facendo qualcosa
che nessuno di noi intorno a noi ha
fatto e non sto parlando di dire
che la Terra è rotonda mentre tutti
dicono che è quadrata sto parlando anche
di Piccole scelte nella quotidianità di
ognuno di noi è proprio perché nessuno
di noi ha fatto queste cose e Anzi ci
scoraggerà No probabilmente le persone
anche quelle che ci vogliono più bene ci
diranno ma cosa stai facendo Ma dove
stai andando No ma la ricetta non è
questa Beh in effetti Come dare di Torto
la ricetta non è questa ma dobbiamo
essere pronti anche a questo è parte del
processo è qu quasi
indispensabile E allora per ritornare al
quesito iniziale no ce la faranno i
nostri due cavalieri a trovare una
risposta alla
domanda loro non lo so forse andranno
avanti a discutere all'infinito Ma io
volevo provare a dare una risposta ed
affermare che se lasciamo che il magico
mondo dell'immaginazione e della
fantasia invada un poco di più la nostra
realtà di tutti i giorni e
viceversa se prendiamo la realtà non
come una verità assoluta e immutabile Ma
come uno spunto per cambiare e per avere
nuove idee il prodotto che ne verrà
fuori Sarà sicuramente più interessante
più potente e forse anche più utile per
tutti
Grazie